thank you
[Music]
Nigerian officials have seized thousands
of blank
fouls teddy bears
that's wholesome no because there's
something inside chalkboard erasers no
Nigerian huh thousands of princes
Nigerian prince oh [ __ ] Kayla's the
cocaine kilos of cocaine no
no thousands no drugs
I'm out of ideas eggs
thousands of
spells n95 masks an independent DVD
movies
thousands of donkey penises what
they close it's like the catalytic
converter of Africa
I try to go down there I'ma just take
this off now
someone took my doggy's dick yes wait I
gotta go to work
uh so sacks of donkey male genitals were
C's at the international airport in
Lagos which is Nigeria's largest city
try to help bigger penises or stronger
surgery are they selling it to Chinese
for medicine yeah herbal medicine yeah
so there's an investigation that has
been launched to find out more
information about these items
um these are meant these these kinds of
donkey genitals uh are rare they are
donkey skins which are the sacks right
the ball sacks yeah the the sack of the
generals they are known to frequently be
exported or smuggled out of the country
and in July the customs of Nigeria
seized 116 000 worth of donkey skins
being smuggled into the country from 90
which is right by them
they're trying to curb the export of
donkey skins which has drastically
diminished the country's population of
the work animals particularly in the
North
and Nigerian senators in 2021 proposed
to ban the killing of donkeys and the
export of their skins this is becoming a
big problem because they're killing
other donkeys yeah just before the skin
what is so the application what do you
use skin graft I'm telling you it's
Chinese medicine they're used for
Chinese medicines yeah no way that's the
main thing they're using this right
they're they're mainly exported to China
and the Skins are then
um processed or used in popular
traditional medicine for some old dude
to get a boner I bet you I know dude you
are what you eat you know as a donkey
dick as a kid
um my mom didn't really believe in uh
Western medicine so whenever I got sick
or if anything happened the first place
we go is Eastern medicine and you go to
one of those herb shops right where
there's [ __ ] like 6 000 drawers yeah
and then like this is the way they like
diagnose you you got your hand on her
[ __ ] pad thing
like oh your liver man not good
they just they just feel like oh your
kidney
I'm pretty sure that's my heart but yeah
you know they [ __ ] you they do all this
whole diagnosis and then they go and
they start pulling out drawers and then
so as a kid I would get like this my
medication would be like this uh butcher
paper full of like wasps [ __ ] dried
ants with these [ __ ] berries and [ __ ]
and I'm like you know you're a kid just
like what the [ __ ] is this I have to eat
this at the scale the scale is so uh
yeah it's not like it's like the balance
you don't go like this and it's like oh
it's pretty accurate it's like the guy
is holding it himself and he's going
like this and you see that thing like
this and before he even like stabilizes
it okay good
yeah and then after he makes like like I
don't know like a batch of seven then he
eyeballs it and he goes fake ass witch
right there yeah to take this one it
puts it over there I'm like pretty sure
it all uneven it and I go home and Mom
gotta Brew it and drink it dude did it
work though
did she get better did she I don't even
think I was sick to begin with did you
guys ever make make yard soup the [ __ ]
is that so when I was in Virginia as a
kid we had like all these creeks and
[ __ ] in our backyards and stuff that
sounds awesome me and my neighbors would
would like dig to a certain point and
then next to like one of those beds and
you could always get like a little bit
of water coming up yeah yeah and we
start filling it with little berries and
[ __ ] like little grass and we're
talking about how it's soup or something
yeah yeah but like that's what this [ __ ]
sounds it sounds no different than that
that's exactly what it is dude it's
intuitive I feel like as humans like you
just go out and you just want to make
potions and [ __ ] you know so but it's
just weird how no matter what we tell
the world but like hey guys like
drinking Tiger Blood doesn't do anything
like congrats it's like doesn't stop
people from wanting because people say
[ __ ] like you are what you eat yeah yeah
you want to be a tiger tiger blood yeah
and there's one of these herb shops in
every single Asian City around the
universe yeah and they're always in
business
well I think it's because is the placebo
effect if you think it works and it
actually helps you and then if they
really do get cured because of placebo
they really believe in it yeah so it if
it works for them that's probably why
it's still been around for thousands of
years you know why do people buy farting
jars
who buys parts of jars people actually
buy farts a jars bark why do you think
Spencer's still in business it's a joke
dude bro they get that chick I'm on
wrath and she's like I'm ripping ass to
the jars today and then she sends them
out she [ __ ] says about 80 bucks a
pop or something whoa dude millionaires
off of these shoes now you know fans are
opening that [ __ ] and just going like
they're just getting ready to jack off
yes oh it's like she [ __ ] just just
blurted in my face yeah I bet you could
trap a fart in a in a mason jar you know
yeah totally can I think Bart should do
that you should sell your farts because
Bart's farts we've talked about birds
farts many times I mean he'll never
[ __ ] do it because he's not a real
business man
he's not gonna do it I don't eat a whole
can of beans and I'll [ __ ] just load
them up dude when I was a kid my dad
used to take me to this Chi doctor
because he I couldn't breathe out my
nose for my whole life
and it was this guy that my dad made
friends with and he was like a very
successful cheat doctor like he would do
like 20 minutes for people like Qigong
type yeah he would just feel you up he
would just just do this bro he would
charge they stay like two inches away
they're like this yeah he would charge
like like 120 bucks for like 20 minutes
bro what the [ __ ] and he would have
people coming to him all day like he had
all like all kinds of a-listers that
would come see him like people really
believed in the [ __ ] it probably works
yeah nah
probably so I would go and I was like
probably like eight and I was like dude
every Saturday morning my dad would
always take me because he was homies
with the guy so he would take me before
his uh all the rest of his clients so
it'd be like 7am on a Saturday morning
you know we can't even watch your
cartoon you can't watch no cartoons bro
and I [ __ ] all the time even when I
was like eight I was like this [ __ ]
don't work bro like I don't want to do
this I got a deviate it yeah bro like I
can't breathe like it's not helping and
like to his credit he would just stay
over me and just do this and it would be
crazy because you feel tingly you do
feel it you I don't know what it is
energy but I think I think it's like
when people do that and you start
getting tickled exactly yeah
it's a predictive sense exactly or it
could just be his body heat because he
has warm-ass hands yeah that's still
energy too it's just a slow version of
when someone does this and you go like
that
but it doesn't fix my nose being able to
breathe I used to go for like two three
years probably actually longer and you
could have suffocated in there I just
was like dude I would just sit on his
[ __ ] lazy boy chair so you didn't
believe that yeah you didn't believe me
yeah that's what I was gonna say you
didn't believe you didn't allow the
Placebo to take a place but I'm also
eight years old if you point negative
Nick back then I was a team boy you
didn't know how to tap into your Chi yet
bro you know
[Laughter]
lay over the table my mom is taking this
place to have bloody nose right that
runny nose as a kid in my [ __ ] back
skin cracked so this back skin so she's
taking this doctor why she goes like
this
ah okay [ __ ] right so you she would just
pull the skin off
it goes grabs my backseat kicks it right
she tries to pull the skin off of your
spine and you would actually wait and
you would hear pops and [ __ ] you know
what my nose just cleared up and it
hurts it hurts like [ __ ] and I was like
and I was like what the [ __ ] and then I
would do that all the time and I'm like
I'm crying I don't want to go there
because I know it's so painful and later
on I just found out I have like seasonal
allergies
this is all it took I don't need my
[ __ ] back skin crap
what if that g that Chi doctor saved
your life like what if your dad was
going to him saying I think I'm gonna
throw away this kid man he's can't
[ __ ] breathe he's just no good and
he's like let me work on him yeah yeah
the placebo worked on my back that's
what it was yeah dude that's crazy but
either way I'm still here today so I
think I'm healthy I think I'm good have
you done it have you done any Eastern
medicine [ __ ] uh yeah all the time when
I was younger they did the cupping thing
yeah yeah yeah they should they do that
[ __ ] that's Eastern uh acupunctures
Easter but there's actual application to
that yeah
not all Eastern medicine is probably
like but the elephant tusk in your ass
doesn't do anything yeah yeah I don't
know but they haven't researched that
enough yeah he's willing to tie it and
everything
the gas station no headache no head no
headache anymore massive
erections I do believe in energy work
though because that [ __ ] is even though
it is in your head it's like well what
if you can somehow control it to get
your head Placebo is real that's just
the place because ultimately like
ultimately it's it's your mind that
heals it not whatever just your active
invading the dumbness the chakras yeah
yeah but like what kind of energy work
do you like to do
um
I don't I don't do energy work myself no
but like when you go get work done to
you when I get I've never had it done to
me I've seen it though so so my friend
does energy work and uh he works on
people's like back problems and stuff
and there would be this like 60 year old
guy that's had chronic back pain right
and he would just straight up go up to
him and like work on his back while he's
like under medicine because he you know
there's like people that do like plant
medicine and then they they work on
people right what's plant medicine like
herbal there's like Ayahuasca there's
like rape there's like
that
the answer to everything dude like he
turns off his brain and kind of just
lets his hands do the work and then and
he just always goes under the trousers
yeah but like my question is I'm not I'm
not trying to like [ __ ] on anything I'm
just trying to like Curious like I'm I'm
curious I don't know what what that
means when you say like body work like
what is he doing so he what he tells me
okay this is how he explains it to me so
when he's under medicine like obviously
you're in an altered state of
consciousness so he doesn't like
oh your back is in pain
he's like my childhood [ __ ]
oh my mom was so mean to me he's like
yeah
hold up
can I get can I get a large pizza yeah
hang on
but anyway like the point the point is
for him is for him to like connect to
his self right and whatever right and so
he uses that to kind of feel out like
what's going on with that guy's back so
that's his superpower he takes whatever
he needs to become a doctor or whatever
it's not a doctor like that like he's
he's like he's like he's sober for this
[ __ ] I can't [ __ ] think the way he
explains it is there is built up energy
in this guy's back and he's trying to
find those spots like without the guy
telling him anything right and that he
just does some work and moves it around
and then next thing you know the guy's
like dude it's gone like his chronic
back pain gone he's like the guy put a
place on my back
lighter and lighter and lighter and
lighter and then it was gone no but it's
not the first time that's happened
because like I he's he's worked on other
people too same thing like he does he
just shuts off his brain and lets his
hand do the work I love that business
model that's crazy it just can't be
faulted it's crazy because you can't
explain how it works but to them it
works so it's like explain are you tired
you're tired oh okay here's coffee okay
are you sleepy okay hold on
he sleeps on the guy's back and he's
like oh I feel great
I love that [ __ ] man
[Music]
[Music]